Tripp, Gene, congratulations.
You fellas have made it
into the next evolution
of this competition.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this.
GENE: Dang.
[laughter]
Your final
challenge is to forge
a Marine Corps officer's sword,
also known as a Mameluke.
You'll have four days
at your home forges
in which to complete
this challenge.
And at the end of
those four days,
you'll return and
present your swords
to our panel of expert judges.
And after they've
thoroughly tested them,
they'll move one of you forward
to represent the Marine Corps
at the Battle of the
Branches final competition
and give you that opportunity
to win a check for 50 grand.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
- Bro.
Good luck.
GENE: So it's day one.
I'm back at my home forge
in Springfield, Virginia.
So I think the more
difficult aspects of the
build are the parameters
that I have to build it to.
It's very specific
and very tight.
So we'll see what happens.
Because the parameters are so
tight on the bend of the blade,
my crazy idea is to
take a 6-by-6 log.
And then I'm going to
remove all the excess wood.
And it's going to leave me with
the blade shape that I want.
Wow.
That went better than I thought.
I plan on heating up the metal
and whacking it on this log.
And it's going to bend
and conform to it.
I've seen a lot of the smiths
straighten out their blade
with a slap on the anvil.
So why not try to do it on a big
old log and put an arch in it?
It seemed to work pretty well.
I, like, just jumped four hours
ahead of my whole schedule.
I'm getting ready
to heat treat it.
I want to keep it thick because
I'm worried about a warp.
Quenching.
[rock music playing]
I am exhausted.
The quench went great.
I'm ready to hit the rack.
All right.
So it's day two.
I'm getting ready to jump
right into some forging.
Hammer time.
Well, this is a very
thin, long blade.
So what's difficult about
a thin and long blade
is just the pure fact
that it's going to warp.
I'm constantly having to
hammer the big curves back out
and try to keep it straight
as possible, all while trying
to draw it out and get the width
and the thickness that I want.
It finally meets parameters.
I'm finally able to
move on to quenching.
If I was to pick up a
crack, I'd start overtiming.
Man, this thing can do
anything in the quench here.
If this thing snaps, we're going
to be close to being screwed,
man.
I don't see any warps.
It looks like it's
pretty straight.
Super stoked about that.
After today, I feel
pretty damn awesome.
Day 3, and I'm ready to
get going on sand casting
a guard for my Mameluke sword.
I've never done any
stand casting before.
Go big or go home.
The consistency of the
sand is the big thing.
I went with playbox sand,
mixed it with some kitty litter
and some water, got to
the right consistency,
and took a shot at it.
I molded some clay in the
rough shape of a guard,
and I used that to
mold the sand around.
I pulled out the clay, and now
I'm ready to heat up my brass.
Let's go cast some metal.
My mold is ready.
My brass is a big pool
of molten hot brass.
I'm ready to pour it in,
so I'm going to go for it.
I'm really hoping this sand
cast goes well because I've
used a lot of time.
And if it doesn't, I don't
know how I'm going to recover.
Moment of truth coming up.
[rock music playing]
Holy cow, it worked.
I can't believe it.
I've just got to knock
the sand off, clean it
up a little bit on the grinder.
That's a guard.
We've got a guard.
TRIPP: Day 4, man.
Today, I've got to sharpen this
blade and get it out of here.
My Ka-Bar didn't do so well
in the rope-cutting test,
so I want this blade
to cut through whatever
those guys are going to
put this thing through.
I want that Marine Corps anvil
pretty damn bad just because I
want to be able to
represent the Marines
in the Battle of the Branches.
I believe I can come
home with that 50 grand
and represent the
Marine Corps very well.
[rock music playing]
Damn.
[laughs]
So this is the start of day 4.
So today, I've got to
start out with getting
it all fit together.
When Doug Marcaida
swings this thing,
it is going to slice
whatever it goes into.
I realized I had a little
bit more time left,
and I wanted to try to put
the names of my competitors
on the blade with some gun glue.
Rick.
Garrett.
Tripp.
Gene.
I'm pretty happy with it.
I know it's going to cut.
I am done.
DOUG: All right, Marines.
Welcome to the kill test.
To find out what lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I'll take your weapon
and deliver killing
blows to this ballistics dummy.
Tripp, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Get it, killer.
Hurrah.
[rock music playing]
Yikes.
Whoa.
Holy moly.
All right, Tripp.
First up, the
handle construction.
It is comfortable.
Your edge here is sharp.
Even cutting through the
skull, no issues at all.
No chipping.
No blunting.
And when you thrust with
this, it penetrates.
It cuts all the way out.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
All right.
Hurrah.
All right, Gene.
You're next.
You ready?
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Oh, no.
It bent it.
DOUG: All right, Gene.
Your weapon picked up
a warp right here, OK?
Your handle, coupled
with blood all over it,
made it very slippery
and hard to hold
onto because it's
blocky and smooth,
and I lost my grip on it.
That's a very dangerous
thing to happen when you're
trying to wield the weapon.
But your edge is still sharp.
Your tip is still thrustable.
And more importantly,
it will kill.
[laughs] That'll work.
[laughs]
All right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength test.
So to test the overall
construction of your blade
and see if they're
going to hold an edge,
I'll be smashing
them into these pots.
Now, remember, this
test is not about what
your swords do to those pots,
but those pots to your swords.
Tripp, you're up.
You ready?
Ready.
DAVID: OK.
[clanging]
Oh, my gosh.
TRIPP: Yep.
Holy moly.
God, no.
Well, Tripp, a few things
before we get to the obvious.
Your handle construction--
very comfortable.
It felt really good in my hand.
It felt like I could
do a lot with it.
But right there at the edge,
there's that little brown spot.
You had a micro
crack on that edge.
Oh.
Yeah.
So as soon as I hit
that pot, it cut loose.
I loved its feel, its shape, and
its look, but obvious problem.
All right, Tripp.
While I know any Marine
could take that blade
and still continue to
fight, in this competition,
your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure
after one strike on that base.
Gene, your blade
only has to survive
one strike on these pots.
The entire Marine championship
for "Forged in Fire"
lies on one swing.
And I've got a big old warp in
my blade, so it's not over yet.
[rock music playing]
[thud]
Nice job.
Gene, first off,
you're in one piece.
You picked up that
bend earlier on,
but you didn't pick up
anymore in this test.
Strong blade.
Held up.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Tripp.
Looks like Gene's blade held up.
That means that you cannot move
forward to represent the Marine
Corps in our next challenge.
Please leave the forge.
Super disappointed.
There's really no
way to tell that you
have, like, any minor cracks
or anything like that.
So you just-- hey, you find
out when you test them.
That's how we found out today.
Get it, brother.
Gene's going to
freaking bring home
that Battle of the Branches
Marine Corps anvil.
He's winning it for
the Marine Corps.
Gene, congratulations.
You've won this competition.
And that means that you're
going to be moving forward
into our Battle of the
Branches final competition
to represent the Marine Corps
at the Marine Corps anvil.
And that's going to
give you an opportunity
to win a check for $50,000.
Good job, brother.
Thank you.
[applause]
Holy cow.
I did not see this coming.
It's been a fun
ride up until now.
But now, I've got to
represent the Marines.
So now, it's game on, and
it's about to get real.
Those other branch service
members better look out.
[yelling]